foreign
let's go out to Jay in Rochester Hills
in Michigan what's up Jay
Dr John deloney what's going on man dude
we are we are rocking onto the break of
dawn my man how are you
I am doing great man thank you so much
for taking the time to take my call you
got it yeah man before we get started I
want to say that I 100 agree with you
this is the best mental health podcast
on the planet that's what I'm talking
about Jay thank you so so much
um I mean that's like your good deed for
the year you're good man you can just
kind of be a reckless jerk from here on
out you've done your good deed thank you
so much man no problem brother no
problem all right so hey um in a it it
almost never happens I I got the
entirety of your email this time
um Jenna sent it to me and
um I actually reached out to one of the
one of the two or three experts that I
trust more than anybody in the country
on this particular topic and this
particular issue to get some make sure I
was dialed in and I was going to be able
to help you
um and so man uh I I can't wait to jump
into this stuff
yeah I'm very excited um it's something
I've been struggling with for a while so
I feel like you are the best to give me
some insight on this topic well I I
don't know if I'm the best but I will uh
I'll do my absolute best to tell you
what I do and don't know and um I it's
an honor to just to pull up a seat at
the table and and hear your story so
tell me what's going on
Yeah man so
I I feel like I am a very disciplined
person
um
but I have a real bad struggle and
addiction to sugar and I feel like it is
my coping mechanism after a bad day
I feel like I could do I can go two to
three weeks without having it and all of
a sudden if I have a bad day at work
or or a few bad days of work I end up
having
three large Milkshakes that week and
it's like a never-ending cycle and I
really just struggle with it and I want
to kick that habit and
I already work out you know I work out
five to seven days a week and
um I actually use you're a big fan of
this guy I'm a huge fan of this guy of
Dr Lane Norton I use carbon I track
everything but it's like
something comes over me
where the sugar dopamine kicks in and I
just have to have it and I'll do
whatever it takes to
get sugar
so you are a uh yeah Lane is incredible
um a brilliant Guy and um
I can't I I kind of want to look around
to make sure this isn't I'm not in a
weird dream and I'm calling myself on my
own show all right
um right so
why do you work out
I work out well I'm
29 now so I'll be 30 next year so lately
I've been working out to keep myself
healthy but before then I've always just
loved working out I love the the stress
reliever that it brings
when did you start working out
oh I would say I've been working out
since I was a young kid young teenager
so right when I play sports you know
you you wrote something here on your
email
that
I I raised a flag for me okay I'll use
yeah you wrote here
I'm afraid if I don't get my poor
choices with food under control
I'm gonna die early or end up on my 600
pound life that show
yeah that's um
that tell me I'm wrong that sounds like
somebody
who is looking in the mirror and is not
happy with who they see
I would say that's a fair statement
so let's move the food stuff down I I'm
on a scale of one to ten what is the
shame intensity after the third
milkshake
oh man I would say
uh 10 for sure like go
in a hole and
don't come out
and words like you are sick you're
disgusting
that's ridiculous am I onto it yeah
you're on to it like what's wrong with
you bro why would you do this that's
horrible you know better than that whose
voice is that Jay that's not yours whose
voice is that
uh
the the standards I put on myself maybe
nah dude somebody told you that your
value was
not innate
yeah
who said you better you better dance you
better perform for me or your value and
lovability goes down who said that
I can honestly say that
it probably was someone in my within my
small circle of family growing up okay
or maybe or or maybe I dealt with a
great deal of trauma being raised by a
single mother that
I think and thought that I had to become
a people pleaser
to make everyone and everything around
me happy and so when things didn't go
that way
I feel like I would put myself in a bad
position and stress myself out and if
that makes sense well yeah because
one person gets hurt
in the presence of a rock star people
pleaser
and that's the people pleaser because
you gotta you gotta sacrifice yourself
to make sure everybody else is okay
and if you grew up in a house uh a
traumatic house you grew up in a house
that was that was a mess it was chaotic
um single mom it was just tough
um
it's very common that people exit that
situation by controlling every possible
variable
I will control every every perception
somebody has of me every word that comes
out of my mouth my posture how clean my
clothes are my the Precision of my
workouts the the the amount of to the to
the to the t uh the the calories that go
in my body it it is that you
that's me okay
and
at some point that grip you have
your body gets exhausted
because you can't hold it all
right
and then We're Off to the Races right
we're off in the drive-throughs
exactly yeah man you're you're talking
to me
reach into the choir for sure
so
um
guys have become good good buddies of
mine
um there's basically two people I trust
when it comes to Fitness Nutrition
it's Lane Dr Norton and Sal and Adam and
Justin with the Mind pump guys
and so when you hear this episode
entirely what you'll hear is beforehand
before this call I was on the phone with
Sal and I actually read him your email
and I said hey man
um Sal's an expert he's been a personal
trainer for years and then he started
training trainers and he got so fed up
with the nonsense and the Fitness and
Nutrition industry they started their
own show and they're incredible they
just are doing great work
and one thing that um I'll never forget
he told me in person when we were
hanging out in San Jose and that he just
reiterated
um on the call before this one is most
people go to the gym because they hate
themselves
they think they're disgusting and
they're trying to going to the gym is a
punishment for being disgusting
for being lazy
and what he said was outside of a few
people on Instagram
that has a fail rate of 80 to 90 percent
over the Long Haul
same with restrictive dieting pick a
diet I'm going full this full that keto
this full protein this what
fail rate fail rate fail rate because
the root is I hate you and you're gross
I am going to beat you into submission
and all of us when we're beaten long
enough we revolt
right right or when life gets really
stressful
our
hitting ourselves and hating ourselves
doesn't doesn't
um
keep the stress away
and so it's not a prophylactic for
stress it's still going to show up and
so we don't have another alternative so
what do we do we go grab gummy bears and
more ice cream
and then that shame spiral starts dude
and we recommit to our apps the next day
and we start the whole Loop over it
yes it it's kind of like a never ending
cycle right yes
so
I'm just meeting you I can tell in five
minutes talking to you like you and I
would hang out I like you
yeah
and
you have one path forward
where did your dad go
he wasn't there he went to Tennessee
with uh another woman
when did he go
I was six
six years old
I'm guessing there's a six-year-old that
sits inside your chest
wondering what the hell was so bad about
Jay that Dad wouldn't stick around
and I imagine there's a 14 year old boy
that sits inside of Jay's chest that
says I'll show him
I'll show you all
right
there's a 22 and a 25 year old Jay
who's getting really exhausted
how old are you now
I am
29.
are you running out of gas
running out of gas man that's why I want
to fall with you I got on the hotline
and called Dr John
thank almost all e
Jay's worth being loved man
yeah
and that jar that you've got sealed shut
inside that chest you gotta open it
and if you're like me you got to do it
with a therapist counselors hard stuff
there
because it feels like if I open this
thing you don't want to know the dragons
that come out
and what I'll tell you is something you
already know is that the dragons are out
you think you got them under control but
you don't
the only path forward for for any of us
man
including me including you
is just what my friend Sal says I have
to go to the gym
with a smile on my face because I'm
choosing to care for a guy that's worth
being loved
I like that I'm going to
be a guy who's a good Steward of his
body and I'm not going to eat that not
because it's not freaking delicious
I'm gonna do it because I love this guy
enough
that I want him to feel good in an hour
or two when his blood sugar crashes
through the floor
so I'm good guys thank y'all so much
and do you see the difference between
that approach how light that is and how
like what a what a gentle touch that is
moving through the world and how
different it is than
I don't eat carbs I don't eat carbs I
don't eat carbs and then you were just
huddled under a blanket eating a bag of
chips watching a movie on a Saturday
night all by yourself I mean you see the
difference
yeah absolutely
but I really do so to piggyback up off
of that can I ask you a question if you
don't mind bring it
so I love that thought and ideology
how do I make it practical on a
day-to-day basis
three three things okay
um
you have to choose man God I hate this I
would do anything I gotta I will give
two books uh signed books of in to any
of your choice to anybody who calls it
if they will come up with a better word
for what I'm about to say
the word here Jay is mindfulness and I
hate the word it sounds like some dude
with a beard on a cloud you know like in
a kind of a dressy thing
here's what it is when you start to
reach for whatever it is you're gonna
reach for
being able to extend that gap between
what I feel like I need to do and the
thing I'm about to do I need some gummy
bears right now I need to go grab get a
milkshake I am getting that pizza out
can you pause long enough to ask
yourself
what am I covering up here
what is this gonna do for me
and what we're doing here in a lot it's
it's it's it's the word I use when I'm
talking to to couples and to parents and
to folks working on like you know
working through ADHD or their OCD or
whatever and it's the same word Sal used
when he's talking to people about their
eating and and exercise habits it's
simply learning a new set of skills
you're not a piece of trash Jay
you're not some kind of undisciplined
loser
you showed up to a basketball game man
you never dribbled a basketball before
these are new skills
I gotta learn new skills
I have one skill for dealing with stress
and it's junk food
cool I'm gonna learn some new skills
that means when I get stressed and I'm
about to grab it I gotta catch myself
and then go huh
what's another thing I could do that
could it would make me feel good in this
moment
and we're gonna practice it for some
people it might be doing 50 jumping
jacks sprinting down the street grabbing
a Diet Coke it could be any number of
things it's going to be different for
everybody but we're gonna practice it
it's a new set of skills
I like that there's a um Dr Judd Brewer
I think he's out of Yale has a uh an app
that's for anxiety and for stopping
smoking and he is crushing all the uh
traditional methods to stop smoking with
an app and all it is is he just wants
you to be very mindful when you're
smoking
how do you feel right before you smoking
right afterwards right and it's
disgusting it's your hands stink your
clothes stink right feels good for a
second the buzz is fine and then it's
they say people just quit because
they're thoughtful about it
and so it's thinking about how am I
gonna feel in an hour after I just
nailed this mint chocolate chip ice
cream
I'm gonna feel ashamed I'm gonna feel
gross I'm gonna feel lethargic I'm not
gonna right all those things I'm just
gonna be mindful of it
um the second thing is is at some point
you're gonna have to get a counselor and
sit down and talk about your childhood
sit down talk about your adulthood and
make some plans for who I'm gonna be in
the back half of my life
all right
have you ever done that
I have not but I am totally open to it
my whole thing is as long as the outcome
is growth and peace I'm all for it
you're gonna you're gonna have to learn
what peace feels like because right now
peace feels like stress for you
peace is a fairy tale for Jay
when you're peaceful I I'd be willing to
bet money that you create chaos in your
life
yeah is that true
yeah
chaos feels
um normal it feels home
so for some people the the challenge is
you've got to go move your body you got
to go exercise you gotta go walk you
gotta go be with friends for you it's
gonna be the opposite you're gonna have
to learn peace you're gonna have to
learn Sabbath you're gonna rest
my friend Ian simkin says if busyness is
your drug
stress will feel like a rest will feel
like stress
that's you
that's you taking every variable every
variable and just letting your hands off
the wheel and you're going to find out
that the card isn't crash it's amazing
and here's the third thing you got to do
you gotta find one or two other grown
men in your area and tell them what
you're going through
all of it
okay and that's probably the scariest
thing of all
I can do it can you promise
promise man all right here's my here's
my uh
here is my uh uh wager with you okay
yeah let's do it I want you to go to the
Mind pump website all their workouts
their maps program Maps
they're the ones I work out with at my
house okay
okay I think they're some of the best in
the country
you pick anyone you want and you email
uh Jenna back and uh I'll give it to you
for free
you like how I did that they're actually
giving it to me and then I'll give it to
you for free but I like taking credit
for it
wow if anyone that you want okay man
that's number one wow
number two
I'm gonna give you anything you want out
of out of my store okay
questions for humans books whatever that
is
if you call me back in three months and
let me know how your how your counseling
sessions going
how your new approach to my friend Jay
is going
the mindfulness
and
how your search for
some grown men Francis ago
all right the fair
before you go to bed tonight I want you
to write six-year-old Jay a letter
okay and I want you to let six-year-old
Jay know
hey I see you buddy come here
dad left because something was wrong
with him not you
dad missed out on the greatest gift
that any man can get
that's holding their
baby
and be able to walk alongside that mess
of a little girl or little boy for the
duration of their life
okay
and tomorrow I want you to write 14 year
old Jay a note
says Dear 14 year old Jay
I'm 29 now you can stop fighting
stop running stop fighting I got this
bro you're a freshman in high school go
play
and I want you to physically feel inside
your chest
14 year old Jay leave your body
he's off to play
he'd been fighting your fights for a
long time
this is Jay choosing freedom
and then with your therapist you're
going to write a letter the 29 year old
Jay
the one that looks at you in the mirror
every morning you're gonna let that Jay
know hey man you've had a rough go of it
and you're still here
you're stronger than most and braver
than most and more disciplined than most
you've been through hell and back and
through hell and back again
and you still stand
and now we're gonna
be a good Steward of our body because we
get to
because we care for ourselves so much we
love ourselves so much not because we
have to not because we're fat because we
hate ourselves because we get to
and now we're talking about long-term
life change of course you're gonna use a
carbon app of course we're going to use
a workout program of course we're going
to do those things
but we're gonna duel them out of care
and love not out of hate
and you're worth being loved Jay
you're good man the world is better
because you are in it
all this turns around
when you believe that too my brother